[Music]  Martin  the Lycans have resolved to exterminator  they have a new leader Marius he wants  to blood Italy  if they use it that I can I'll be  limitless  there is never being a large-scale like  in the time there is never been a Marius  attacker do I look worried  you must come north you will find  answers there  Paul has followed you here  Marius if you want to win this war you  will need to go further than even a  warrior of your renown has ever ventured  before impossible  [Music]  looking for someone  [Applause]  there's nothing stopping it now  what I want is your blood come and guess  it  she is the purest of us all I'm not that  pure impossible  there's nothing